welcome to best life 30 your 30-day
journey to creating the best life
possible for yourself you can just watch
this video or if you want to sign up for
the entire series for free and get the
companion bonus worksheets that go with
this video check the link in the
description below alright so today is
day 18 and we're going to learn how to
prioritize our time one of the lines
from right out of the five am Club is
one of the DNA's of legendary is
longevity so if you look at the Picasso
is the John Michele Basquiat you look at
the great sports champions you look at
the great history makers they were much
better at energy management than time
management and so we're in a war against
distraction right now and what we really
have to do is optimize our energy how do
I do it well I mean I get to the morning
routine which which the whole book is
based on but it's really quite powerful
because if you start your day with
sweaty exercise you're actually going to
activate a pharmacy of mastery that
exists in every human brain I know you
love the neuroscience you're gonna
release BDNF which is brain derived
neurotrophic factor that's gonna
actually accelerate your processing it's
actually going to repair brain cells
that have been damaged by stress you're
gonna release the neurotransmitter
dopamine which is the the fire
neurotransmitter which we all need as
entrepreneurs and business builders and
and servants of humanity cortisol the
fear hormone is highest in the morning
so exercising first thing in the morning
is going to reduce that I'm getting into
my 20-20-20 formula but I mention it
because it is a way to maximize your
energy so talk to us about the 20-20-20
I mean you sort of started it there with
the the sweaty exercise but what's the
rest of that formula which is pretty
powerful sure so the new book is all
about rising at 5 a.m. and that's
because if you look at the great
creatives and the great Saints and the
great humanitarians and the great titans
of industry many of them got up at 5
a.m. even right now you've got Tim Cook
and you've got Howard Schultz and it
goes on and on before the Sun rises is
the time of lease distract
before the Sun rises where you can build
intimacy and fluency with what you want
to stand for in your day before the Sun
rises and the luxury and tranquility of
the early morning hours you can do that
deep in or work that will allow you to
go out in the world and play at your
best so what the 20-20-20 formula is is
simply this there's three pockets the
first pocket is move five to five twenty
if you get into the sweaty exercise
because like I mentioned it releases
neurotransmitters there reduces the
Corozal increases your metabolic rate
which gives you more energy so now and
sort serotonin as well which gives you
joy so now it's 5:20 fundamentally you
feel different you have energy your
state is strong you've got a fire in
your belly you accelerate your focus
5:22 540's the second pocket of the
20-20-20 formula which is reflect we
live in a world where a lot of people
are busy being busy but what's the point
of being busy around climbing the wrong
Mount Everest and so clarity is one of
the DNA's of mastery you know this if
you talk to the titans of industry and
you talk to the people really getting
traction around their ambition these are
people who have a monomaniacal focus on
the few things that matter they have an
obsession bordering on a possession
around the few priorities they want to
build our life around
and so 520 to 540 the second pocket
you're writing a journal you meditate
you visualize you do what I call them
the book a blueprint for a beautiful day
or you just sit in solitude and you
think and you ponder and you reflect and
then the final pocket is 5:40 to 6
o'clock and this is the victory hour the
final pocket is grow but if you look at
the greatest billionaires I've coached
many billionaires over the past 20 years
if you look at the greatest producers on
the planet these people have one thing
in common they are ridiculously curious
and no matter how much money they make
and no matter how much impact they have
they maintain a white belt mentality one
of the keys to epic performance is a
relentless commitment to daily growth so
that's the 20-20-20 formula that the 5
a.m. method is built around and the
premise is basically this as you begin
your day so you handcraft the rest of
your day and if you have consistently
great days you're gonna have
consistently great weeks quarters a year
and a lifetime so your days are life in
miniature and you've got to get those
morning's calibrated if you really want
to win when you look at prioritizing it
really lives in and I must say this word
and you're probably not gonna want to
hear it but when I tell you it's a
game-changer when you master and just
for now begin to operate inside of time
management I use some resist time
management because I'm a free spirit
slash people will call me a rebel back
in the day meaning I didn't want to be
controlled I want it I'm a butterfly I
wanted to I wanted to soar I wanted to
be free or the reality is that when you
manage your time more effectively you
actually create more freedom that was a
huge army somebody's gonna be lil right
now like break through out loud because
when you time manage meaning I'm gonna
use better blocks of my time let me give
you some examples for that let me use
better blocks in my time meaning I'm
only gonna go on my email three times a
day I go on my email about 9:30 between
9:20 and 9:40 I go on my email I stay in
my email for 30 minutes I'll go back in
my email about 3 o'clock in the
afternoon I stay in my email again for
about 30 minutes I go back a name one
more time at 6 p.m. I stay in for about
30 minutes that's it I don't go in 19
times I don't go on 20 times because 3
times a day gives me adequate time to
see
what's in there see what's new and act
appropriately otherwise it's throwing me
off I'm blocked my day about ninety
minutes each time blocked to do a task
even if a task only takes me 30 minutes
I timed like 90 minutes because I get
distracted but when you time block your
day and then you schedule each day not
every day looks the same I have a time
block for everything I need to do for
seven days out of the week can you
believe that in that time I got more
things done you have to become
comfortable with your note my
grandmother says baby
she starts every sentence with baby baby
if you want your yes to have more value
you need to learn how to exercise your
note see your yes might not have this
value anymore why because you give it
away too much you give it to too many
people you give it away too often
you're always over committing and then
you feel drained and frustrated and you
don't have gratitude in your heart
because you're over committed well that
all started with a yes that should have
been enough or should have been a I'd
love to but not now and so number two
number one is more effective time
management that has your agenda in it it
has your priority priorities in it right
now your agenda is covered with everyone
else's task I often I heard once if you
don't have a your agenda then you're
gonna work for somebody else's agenda
and so number one is your time measure
with your agenda and number two is
operating utilizing and being
comfortable and I know and not an
attitude knows not to like oh thanks no
like no not that mm-hmm just a no not
now
no I I would love to but my plate is
full I'm free in 90 days just don't make
no no energy just not now don't be
surprised when everyone comes to you
you're great you're amazing you're
brilliant look at you you're on this
channel so you know you smart you want a
better life you want an abundant life of
course you're here of course I do I want
you and your priorities matters what is
time how do you know when it's a long
time or how do you know when it's a
short time it's not because it's 10
minutes or 10 hours how many been in 10
hours and time flew because you loved
what you're doing didn't have any sense
of time whatsoever how many fact that
experience ai how many to have 10
minutes feel like 10 years you want to
kill somebody to get out of the
situation so what is time time is
emotion got to remember that time is
emotion what you're really managing is
emotion in other word for that would be
meaning or fulfillment focus is power
but you're gonna take it take it back
take back that power and you got to know
when you do that that focus how to chunk
it how to group it so you're not
overwhelmed let me show you how to make
it simpler when mass information is
coming at you you get overwhelmed most
of us are great deletion creatures we
delete most of life right now there are
millions and things around you you can
be focusing on thinking about getting
meanings to making decisions about what
to do millions right now you can be
focusing on the blood rushing through
your left eardrum or the feeling of your
skin against your body but most of you
delete that you don't even think about
clothing against your skin till I
mention it or your heart beat most of
the universe you've deleted because you
go crazy if you try to think about it
all because human beings have a limited
amount they can focus on at one time but
most of your stress is because you're
thinking about too many things at once
in fact when people don't do things if
not because they can't it's not even
because they don't want to it's because
of the way they are focusing on what I
call chunking
things when people don't follow through
here's what they do give an example who
here believes exercise is very important
but you don't exercise regularly let me
see your hands raise your hand more
hands than most of us once great sore
hand right now who here really focuses I
should say exercises regularly regimen
regulate okay good who here does not
exercise regularly even though you
believe it's important just be truth
okay
so let's see what the difference is here
a person who does not exercise regularly
I want you raise your hand and I want
you to tell me why you don't exercise
regularly and be truthful okay yes sir I
don't have the time that is that true he
even knows it's not sure he's gonna
answer you first no but it feels like he
doesn't have the time because time is
emotion and he's got so many other
things he is focused on getting results
in the adding this to the list seems
like a lot right and the other things
are very important to him like his
business I don't have a time he has the
time what's the real reason he doesn't
do it because of the way he thinks about
exercise when he focuses on what it
would take to exercise he does it very
differently than someone who follows
through when you think about exercising
what's involved
okay he starts thinking about I gotta
get to mild 14 of a London Marathon and
that even the thought of trying to get
to the 14th mile much less the 20 good
mile is like beyond my imagination right
now so he is what I call over chunked
he's not thinking about what he wants
he's thinking about what's painful
he's just saw a perfect example he's not
even thinking about victory or
succeeding so the chance of him
following through on something that he
associates major pain to when he could
do something else right now he can feel
confident or successful at his chances
of falling to our very limited how many
would follow that say I his focus is on
failure his focus is on pain that's why
he isn't following through ok
he's also focused on the 14th mile of a
marathon rather than today's workout
which one seems more daunting to you so
when you think of what it here's also
he's thinking about he's thinking about
the process not the outcome or results
he wants and when you think about what
it's gonna take to do something usually
it takes a lot and you're not gonna want
to do it so he's over chunk himself he's
trying to eat the whale hole without
taking any smaller bites that it seems
too big for him so he says we'll all do
it win later
it's my Australian friends would say
later all right and of course the
problem with doing it tomorrow is when
you get to tomorrow tomorrow's today
tomorrow never comes
so and you keep promising yourself by
the way what does this do to you
emotionally when you keep breaking your
own promises with yourself or you keep
failing to do things that you know are
important does it increase your length
level of certainty and confidence you
know what it does is it roads and when
you wrote confidence in one area believe
it or not it affects the other areas too
do you believe on that don't believe me
what about your own life experience
maybe not one area but it starts to be
multiple areas it sure does another
reason why somebody has an exercise or
do anything is because they don't just
chunk it too big they chunk it into many
details I'll give you a perfect example
so I asked somebody one time
said okay how important these exercises
all exercise is extremely important
really okay good and tell me why don't
you exercise regularly well I I just
don't have time okay everybody gets that
answer that sounds wonderful so tell me
though don't tell me about how much time
you don't have tell me this when you
think about exercising what do you think
about which is a way of saying what do
you focus on and so this woman says to
me Walt oh my gosh you know I I mean I
know what do you mean what I think about
well let's say I said to you you got to
start exercising and I'm gonna put a gun
to the head of your children and I will
do very horrible things and hurt them
badly if you learn exercise could you do
it oh yeah I could do it you know if I
if you if some mafia person came here it
said I'm gonna kill your children you
don't exercise every day how many think
you can find a way to exercise every day
no matter what your time constraints may
be so remember this remember this change
is never a matter of ability it's always
a matter of motivation I'll say that
again change is never a matter of
ability it's always a matter of
motivation or Drive having strong enough
reasons if you got a strong enough
reason you can figure out the time
couldn't you so the biggest part of life
and time management is knowing what you
want and having enough reasons to follow
through I don't know what percentage of
human effort is spent in
counterproductive activity you know I'm
not an absolute cynic about that but I
mean when I talk to undergraduates I
asked them you know how much time do you
waste every day by your own reckoning
and it's somewhere between five and
eight hours you know it's a lot of time
well I usually walk through my walk with
students students through an economic
analysis of that I said well you know
why don't you value your time at 50
dollars an hour and calculate for
yourself just exactly what you're doing
to your future by your inability to
discipline yourself it's worth thinking
through in any case people do waste a
lot of time and they are they also act
counter productively a lot of the time
there are a lot of things that are a
waste of time you know and you think
about your life
I think I often tell people that I work
with if you can get because people
people have very high standards for how
they want their work life to be and and
I said look if you can get your work
life to be where you enjoy half of it
that is a home that is amazing because
very few people ever achieve that
because the truth is everything comes
with overhead that's reality everything
comes with pieces that you don't like
you could be a Supreme Court justice and
they're still gonna be pieces of your
job you don't like you can be a
university professor and it's still
gonna be Peter if to go to committee
meetings and you have to do things you
know there every job comes with pieces
you don't like and we need to say that's
just how that's part of it and and and
not resent those pieces or try not to
but also try to minimize them I tell
senior executives you should have the
least stress you know there's this weird
I think false idea that CEOs I'm a CEO
there's this false idea that CEOs are
under the most stress well I look at
that I'm like why you're in charge
why don't you delegate the stress
it's your choice and so it's you have to
figure out how to set up your life in
such a way that you can minimize the
things and I find people don't dislike
hard work but people dislike and what it
is being out of control like they can't
control their life they can't control
their environment this happens to me
when I get over scheduled
I hate being over scheduled I want some
time to be able to think and free myself
we all have the same amount of time in
the world nobody has more time than
anybody else and when you become a very
successful person one of the things you
see
to get over scheduled you have this
event you had to agree to do this and
maybe last night you're like why did I
agree to do this I have to go on stage
tomorrow I wish I would really with my
family and you know or I hope maybe not
this case let's say that you like this
one but in general that kind of thing
happens and so you have to guard your
time and and and try to save a little
bit flexible so that's for me it's not a
waste of time but I like to have some
freedom of movement rather than having
every minute of every day scheduled you
need to make fewer decisions fewer
decisions why well as we know and from
neuroscience and we know from
productivity studies that the more
decisions that we actually make the more
our brain becomes fatigued right the
more decisions that we make the more we
utilize the glucose that's really
fueling our willpower that's fueling our
frankly our our ability to make more
decisions and higher quality decisions
matter of fact the more decisions that
you tend to make the less effective
you're going to be over the long term
because you're gonna utilize your
ability and your resources and your
brains power literally your willpower
will go out the window so you want to
minimize the number of decisions you are
making how do you do that
well here's some simple things one stop
browsing you know I know maybe you found
me because you were browsing somewhere
and I hope you make me part of your
focus on your personal development then
I'm a purposeful part of your life but I
can tell you overall browsing completely
wipes out your focus and your willpower
even all these little things you're
focusing on are utilizing all your
brain's resources and over pier time
when you stop browsing and you go back
to focusing on something guess what you
tend not to be able to focus on one
thing and get things done you start
multitasking and doing lots of things
but where your work isn't really focused
nothing gets accomplished so what
happens is your brain is fatigued guess
what happens your brain fatigue you find
yourself sitting with a bag of data
and what do you do when you have a real
control you just flipping randomly
through things do you ever notice that
meaning it's easier to become distracted
the more distracted you are meaning the
more that you aren't focusing on one
thing at a time the more problem you're
going to have later on to complete one
thing at a time and I know that makes
sense but here's this simple solution if
you missed it
stop browsing so much all those browsing
all those tweets that you're reading all
those news feeds that you're reading
guess what every time you look at them
that's what your mind has to do it has
to make a decision pay attention or not
pay attention and that decision is
costing you focal power and resources
later on even if you don't know it
how can people allocate a usable amount
of time to things that they're
passionate about but that are ultimately
gonna take a long time to do how do they
keep that from being overwhelming how do
they make sure that they have success so
they're not discouraged do you encourage
people to think of their life in in a
year chunk in smaller chunks so if it's
a big project like writing a book you
want to say in that year-end holiday
letter that you wrote a book well then
you can start breaking it down and
putting things related to that on each
week's priority list right so maybe this
week you think well what step could I
take toward doing that well I'm gonna
write you know just what is the thesis
of my book alright I did that great
that's all I have to do all right the
next week I'm gonna write maybe a couple
chapters I think could be in that great
you've done it the next week you start
writing a little outlines in each of
those chapters okay
I've done that moving for you don't want
to overwhelm yourself you want to don't
want to bite off more than you can chew
but if you are writing 1,500 words a
week for the rest of the year you're
gonna have a book at the end of it and
not a short one actually so it's these
little things done repeatedly if you
only you know set yourself a very small
goal but you meet it and then you just
keep going you can do amazing things
think of this for a moment do you know
that every living soul gets exactly the
same amount of time exactly the same
amount of time figure it out
you get all there is a hobo sleeping
under a bridge or on a park bench there
is no material possessions none does
nothing of any constructive nature that
person gets exactly the same amount of
time as the most productive
industrialist
in the world we all get exactly the same
amount of time so it's what we do with
the time that makes a difference
I want you to think of the number of
time management programs
almost everyone under the Sun has time
management programs in fact I made one
one time spent a lot of money on it and
then I found out it was a dumb waste of
time and money do you know why time
can't be managed I was having breakfast
with Earl Nightingale one morning and it
was downtown Chicago
and I was going with him on his speaking
engagement and it was early in the
morning he said you want to meet for
breakfast whenever all night you said
you want to meet me I was there and I
always had some well-prepared questions
and I remember asked him I said or how
did you learn how to master time
management yeah we're having breakfast I
can still hear his fork hit the plate
he's what the hell you're talking about
he's I've never mastered time management
nobody masters time management he said
time can't be managed he's I merely
manage activity and he took a little
card out of his pocket and he said every
night before I go to bed I write down
six most important things I have to do
tomorrow these are goal achieving
activities and when I wake up that's
when I start working on and if I don't
get them all done I'll add them to
tomorrow's list you should have about
six now if I have three that I didn't
get done today that doesn't mean I have
nine for tomorrow like six plus these
three those three become part of the six
you have to do the next day when you
wake up you give all your conscious
attention to do those things see you
cannot manage time
but you can manage activity you can
manage your activities make certain that
what you're doing really makes a
difference make certain that you're
spending your time on activities that
are productive that are taking you in
the direction of your goal let's say
you're the most ultra motivated guy in
the world when that alarm clock goes off
there's at least 50% of the time where
you just met that soft little pillow is
just caressing your head and you want to
stay there and it takes discipline to go
nope I'm gonna get up out of this bed
I'm gonna do what I'm supposed to do and
that discipline that you have at that
moment you win that fight that's a big
victory and then that that that pattern
will carry out throughout the day
because once you're up well now that I'm
up I might as well go work out because
I'm already up and I I feel good that I
got up out of bed and I won that battle
let me go win another battle I'm gonna
go get it done and then when you show up
at the office and there's someone that's
got a big box of doughnuts that they're
given away for free by the way so
they're just sitting it's almost like an
insult not to take them but when you've
already gotten up early you had the
disciplinary you already worked out you
had the discipline there and now you see
the box of doughnuts you're like no I'm
not gonna eat the doughnuts no no
doughnuts you're not gonna do it and
that discipline carries on throughout
the day so now you take that and you you
expand that out over a week in a month
and you end up with more discipline and
it starts with that simple act of
getting up and getting out of bed in the
morning we all want freedom right we all
want to have freedom we want we only
have financial freedom we want to have
more free time we don't have physical
freedom that's what we want
everyone wants freedom of course but if
you want to have freedom in your life
the way to get to freedom is is through
discipline it's that's how you get there
so if you want to be if you want to be
financially free you have to have
financial discipline you have to save
your money you have to work hard to earn
more money you have to not buy by stupid
things that you don't actually need
right you need to save that money and
invest it properly all that takes
discipline and if you have that kind of
discipline you'll end up with more
freedom if you want to be if you wanna
have more free time everybody wants more
free time but if you want more free time
how are you gonna get it you have to
have more discipline time management
that shift of like I need to get off of
this because we'll be I'll be spending
time with like my fiancee or with my
family it pop in my head oh my gosh I
need to text this person I forgot I
needed to call them and give this order
fix how do you find that shift just say
you know what I'm spending time with my
family and I'll do it tomorrow but not
like it's an excellent question I think
if you're present to whether or not
you're kind of in the zone of time where
it's cool to be fluid you're kind of
with the family you're also sort of
present on your phone that's cool
if you've decided that because my kids
are starting to complain or my fiancee
is starting to complain that I'm always
like this then you got honor that if
you're gonna say I'm putting down the
phone between 7 and 9 o'clock tonight
and I'm actually just going to be
present with you you've got to honor it
so what I will do is I'll just jot a
note to myself so instead of picking up
the phone
I'll just jot a note down you've had the
experience right where you got to like
be in a meeting at the school or you
have to catch a plane or you've got a
doctor's appointment and have you ever
noticed that when you've got an anchor
like that your whole day condenses and
you're more productive because you've
got this deadline and that's called
Parkinson's law so Parkinson's law it's
a research backed fact that when you
have work to do it will expand to the
amount of time that you have to do it in
so if you have 20 minutes to make a call
how long will it take you if you have
two weeks to make it how long will it
take you correct so if you every day no
phone in your room you set that one
priority that matters to you if you got
time to kind of inch it forward just a
little bit great you've already made
progress you're done for the day then
you look at your phone you also set a
quitting time right then and there the
majority of days you'll honor it and
that quitting time means for me it means
I'm not on my phone and everybody that
works for me if knows if there's an
emergency or if we have to do something
they'll call me so that that helps a lot
much
in our generation is it gradually
through entertainment through television
through media through every way possible
we are living in a generation of the
dumbing down of ideas because we have
traded effectiveness for busyness
statistics say yes somebody out of
Clapham and we are busier than any other
generation we have seen in the last
three to four hundred years we are so
busy where we are busier than a wall
within a one-armed wallpaper hanger
richest BSc because you'll get it later
don't worry about it and they get a hits
in a minute we are just as busy as we
can be and we think because we're busy
we're effective but I want you to
challenge your schedule for a minute and
ask yourself are you are you really
being effective or is your life
cluttered with all kinds of stuff that
demands you and drains you and taxes you
and stops you from being your highest
and best self and are you substituting
busyness and all the chaos that goes
along with business from being effective
let me tell you a bunch of scientists
got together they begin to do some
research and they begin to determine
that 80% of the things we do are busy
things that we do in an area that is not
effective that the average person only
spends 20% of their time doing the
things that they are really gifted at
creating it passionate about excited to
do and the rest of it is all the dismal
dumb stuff that we all have to do in
order to survive just crazy stuff that
we're doing wonder what would happen if
we would go from doing 80% of things
that are busy but not effective and 20%
of the things that are really effective
if we would switch those numbers around
and only give 20% of our time to the
things that we have to do and 80% of our
time to the thing that we were created
to do
[Music]
wonder what would happen to your life
now think about it a minute there's a
lot of things you could take from me and
I could make it you could take my suit I
got another one you can take my car I
could get another one you could take my
house I could get another house but when
you take my time you have taken
something from me that is totally
irreplaceable we take all kind of
classes for money management we know how
to manage our money we know how to
repair our houses we're working on our
hair and our bodies and all of this kind
of stuff we do everything except the
most important thing is to value our
time it takes time to be creative you
were meant to be creative you were
created in the likeness and the image of
a creator and in that likeness and in
that image you have creativity if you
had time you would be creative but in
the absence of time and with busyness
and clutters be the following y'all got
music playing on your phone all kinds of
stuff
and no matter what kind of song you put
on after why you hate to hear it because
every time you hear that sound you know
it's somebody else one something else
from you this taking you away from what
you are gifted and creative to the
question that was asked was how do we
maximize the use of our time here's my
answer and I learnt this from dr. Daniel
Siegel a US UCLA psychotherapist he says
divide them time in 24 hours into the
following sections so sleep time
meditation time exercise sign a
relationship time down time creative and
play time focused work time and when you
eat and when you're doing each of these
things then just do those things don't
do anything else I thought that was very
brilliant and I've been doing this now
for a number of years I sleep at least
six to eight hours a day
I meditate early in the morning for
about one and a half hours I go to the
gym after that I walk between five to
ten miles a day I work from about 9
o'clock to 12 noon then I take a full
hour for a mindful lunch I take the
20-minute walk after lunch then I start
working again in the afternoon around
you know 1 o'clock or so 1:32 even and
then I do a short meditation at 4:30 in
the evening
5 o'clock and I have an early supper on
6:00 and I'm in bed by about 10:00 now
when I'm doing this daily routine then I
feel that my rhythms are in order that
connected to the rhythms of the cosmos
and when I'm speaking to someone I'm
present with them I don't check my
iPhone or my handheld device at the same
time because the cortical brain can only
do one thing at a time so of course the
autonomic nervous system can do many
things at a time do one thing do it
mindfully and do it well pursue
excellence and ignore success stay
detached and divide your time into those
quadrants let's say you have to cook
something that's a you have to bake a
cake or you want to put some rice you
turn on this Tao turn off this town turn
on this town turn off this time it's a
long process
and of course they know won't happen so
this is the story of majority of the
spiritual seekers there off and on and
off and on and off and on Oh does it
mean to say I must be only here there
that's not it
the priority should not shift the
priority is set slowly everything with
the new will slowly organize itself in
that direction because the priority is
shifting this life does not know which
way to go
it is confused every two minutes if you
change the destination on the GPS for
sure it does not know where to go isn't
it so this is what is happening and for
in most people this is why a spiritual
path seems to be orders long impossible
unattainable all these things simply
because people are shifting priorities
all the time now I've got a special
bonus cup that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
best live 30 questions of the day it's
not enough to just watch a video you
have to do something about it so pull
out your worksheets and answer these
questions and if you don't have the
worksheets yet get them for free by
checking the link in the description
below here we go question number one
where do you need to manage your time
better number two how can you chunk down
your goals and number three how can you
make fewer but more important decisions
and if you're doing the best live 30
challenge with me put a hashtag best
live 30 in the comments below we want to
celebrate you you need people in your
life to hold you accountable because you
will never push yourself as hard as you
can go you get a personal trainer
not because of what exercises you should
do you can look that up online the real
value of a trainer is to have somebody
right there in front of you in your face
telling you to do 3 more reps of that
exercise when you want to quit when
you're gonna tap out and if you were by
yourself you'd say I'm done and they say
give me 3 more because all of the growth
happens in that last set if there's
nobody around you to hold you to a
higher standard you'll always know
there's another level but you'll be too
afraid to reach for yourself so let's
use me as an example I want to solve the
world's biggest problem I don't think
people believe in themselves enough it's
why I created this channel and all the
other ones I have and the books and the
speak and everything I do I want to go
out and do this impossible thing that's
never gonna happen
I'm never gonna solve the world's
biggest problem and yet I wake up every
day and I try to do it and I use a
combination of what I call aspirational
mentors which are people like Steve Jobs
and Elon Musk and the people that I
profile on this channel and then I also
do it from people who challenge me one
on one
if you watch my entrepreneur advice
channel I get pushed every week by my
agent Steve by psychologists in
Australia by people who are coaching me
and how to get better and they push me
and they tell me I need to do more they
tell me I'm being an idiot in these
areas like go this is the homework and
the more uncomfortable I feel during
that process usually the better the
advice is if I think about the tour that
I launched last year and now the tour
that I'm doing this year it started as a
free tour and became a paid tour when my
agent Steve pushed me to do it but you
need to charge for this and immediately
my heart's boom boom boom boom boom I'm
scared it means I have to do it having
people around you who can push you to do
the things that you need to do who make
you nervous who make you scared who see
your blind spots who cut through your BS
who tell you that's just for your
talking because we'll come up with
really logical reasons why we can't do
something or aspirational mentors who
when you see how they react to things
how they see things how they understand
the world and then you look at what
you're doing it forces you to be pulled
up it forces you to take the next step
up on the staircase you need to do it
because your environments been perfectly
designed to keep you where you are your
friends your family all of it it's
keeping you exactly where you are and
the difference between where you are now
and where you want to be and where you
can be in a year in two years in five
years in ten years
is gonna be the people you have around
you and how much they're willing to push
you to believe in you to tell you what
you may not want to hear but you need to
hear to grow the challenge yourself and
get to the next level if you want to
join the best life 30 challenge click
the link right here below me or if you
want more videos on how to prioritize
check out the playlist right there next
to me continue to believe and I'll see
you there